[Música]
12 años han pasado desde el
levantamiento contra el gobierno de
muamar algadafi en Libia a lo largo de
esta década y un par de años más el
ánimo de la Revolución la esperanza de
cambio la estabilidad la seguridad y la
democracia pues no sean materializado
del todo Libia se vio inmersa en un
espiral de violencia y la llamada
Primavera árabe en ese país se puede
decir que en muchas formas quedó
inconclusa tal y como le pasa también a
Siria pero con diferentes matices hoy
Libia protagoniza una nueva crisis a
nivel político también el territorio
está dividido en ese país y hay
prácticamente dos gobiernos que
funcionan de manera paralela uno
designado por el parlamento liderado por
fati bachaga es el Primer Ministro
interino del gobierno de estabilidad
nacional o de acuerdo nacional
dependiendo como se traduzca el nombre
El otro es liderado por el Primer
Ministro app de la mid davieva que es
respaldado por la organización de
Naciones Unidas tiene apoyo a nivel
internacional y el encabeza el llamado
gobierno de unidad nacional y ha
asegurado que solo traspasará el poder a
un ejecutivo electo a pesar de que su
mandato ya expiró ya terminó Cuáles son
Entonces los problemas más complejos que
están enfrentando Libia en la actualidad
pues primero como les decía la situación
política actual Esta división de dos
gobiernos también la presencia militar
extranjera me estoy refiriendo a Los
mercenarios del grupo Wagner que está
ligado a Rusia y también a la presencia
de militares turcos la lucha contra el
terrorismo También es importante en la
agenda actual del país la Seguridad
Ciudadana por supuesto y la protección
de las fronteras que siguen siendo
bastante porosas entonces preguntas que
quedan sobre la mesa para el debate que
dejó para Libia la revolución estos 12
años después de la caída de gadafi Qué
papel están jugando organismos
internacionales como por ejemplo la ONU
y países como Estados Unidos y Qué papel
están jugando también las potencias
árabes Como por ejemplo Egipto y los
emiratos árabes cuál puede ser el futuro
panorama político de este país ante
tanta división unas elecciones son la
respuesta hoy en el debate de France 24
hacemos foco en Libia doce años después
del inicio de la primavera árabe y la
posterior Revolución para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a dagoo con Mena él
es historiador africano especializado en
relaciones internacionales él se conecta
desde las palmas de Gran canaria en el
archipiélago de las Islas Canarias en
España y aquí en el estudio de France 24
nos acompaña Alfonso Soria él es
analista consultor internacional también
fue diplomático de Colombia en Argelia y
Egipto antes de comenzar les recuerdo
que quienes nos están viendo en
diferentes plataformas pueden también
seguir la señal de El Debate a través
del streaming y también lo pueden hacer
A través de diferentes plataformas o de
las redes sociales por ejemplo Twitter
Facebook o Instagram nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es el numeral o la etiqueta es
numeral el debate f24 todo junto todo
pegado para que dejen ustedes los
comentarios y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo como les
decía estamos disponibles también en
otros plataformas por ejemplo en podcast
no se encuentran en Spotify en deezer y
en TuneIn
Muy bien pues comienzo entonces dándole
la bienvenida a Dago en Las Palmas en
gran canaria y Dago Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa Punto de
partida para este debate y este análisis
de la situación en Libia que dejó la
revolución en este país 12 años después
qué balance se puede hacer de la
situación que se está viviendo en este
país del norte de África bienvenido
Muchas gracias
En primer lugar quería agradecer La la
redacción de Francia veinticuatro para
por invitarme Pues el balance que se
puede hacer de
de la situación actual en Libia desde mi
punto de vista es que es un verdadero
desastre no porque pasamos de un país
que a pesar de su de sus problemas en
términos de
libertades y de democracia pues tenía un
cierto sistema de
bienestar social y hoy tenemos un estado
fallido Así que desde mi punto de vista
pues la revolución no ha alcanzado la
meta que se había prometido a la
población
al cuando empezó pues este movimiento
social que fue la primera árabe en en
Libia
y paso a preguntarle aquí en el estudio
a Alfonso nuestro invitado Alfonso un
gustazo tenerlo como siempre aquí en
France 24 y la misma pregunta como Punto
de partida qué balance puede hacer usted
qué análisis hace de estos doce años un
caos de verdad Estoy totalmente de
acuerdo y la palabra exacta es desastre
después de ver todos los esfuerzos que
se hicieron en la región por un cambio
dentro de los países de la primavera
árabe nosotros vemos Que Libia es un
estado que hoy en día fallido se muestra
toda la inseguridad de la región pasa
por Libia todo los grandes problemas que
encuentran en los países del norte del
maguefe nosotros lo encontramos se
concentran en Libia los temas de
seguridad el tema del islamismo el tema
de la migración clandestina el tema de
la trata de personas el tráfico de armas
es decir que era un país donde había
donde no conocía los elementos de la
Democracia Pero tenía un régimen
totalitario que
gobernaba y coordinaba
y cuando el 2011 bien estos movimientos
para generar otros cambios creo que 12
años después estamos peor que en El
Punto de partida porque no hay ningún
reconocimiento ninguna garantía de los
Derechos ni libertades que tiene la
población antes Alfonso continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda la inversa ya
le doy la palabra a Dago qué falló
entonces en esta Primavera árabe por qué
en este país No se pudo consagrar es un
poco lo que le pasa también a Siria que
el conflicto quedó estancado y nunca se
llegó a ningún Puerto en Egipto si se
logró hacer una transición Ahora hay un
gobierno militar también muy criticado
desde diferentes puntos a nivel
internacional pero se consolidó un
proceso de de cambio de gobierno
digámoslo así Creo que para analizar el
tema Libia yo pienso queríamos ver una
mirada global Por ejemplo si nosotros
decimos el concepto democracia en túnez
hoy en día es bastante relativo pensaría
Yo bastante entre comillas pensar que el
proceso democrático ha funcionado en la
región pienso que hubo una mala lectura
de occidente de la otan de quién era
moder gafi hay que pensar que el
liderazgo que tenía Libia desde siempre
de 1939 que fue un país que apoyó todo
la la formación de los de los estados no
alineados de El
panafricanismo que habló sobre el tema
de la liga árabe que fue un país que
liberó un cierto de todos modos un tema
a partir del terror o de pero ejercía un
liderazgo como tal lo importante era
someter a ese país que había ejercido un
liderazgo en los años 70 80 en plena
guerra fría y hoy en día nos encontramos
que un país dividido
con una disminuido en todos los temas y
políticamente y de exacto no hicimos
occidente no hizo la lectura de lo que
de lo que es Libia de las divisiones
tanto geográficas a nivel de población a
nivel y Libia fue un país hecho de micro
poblaciones de micro poderes que y de
ciudades que eran importantes pero no el
país como toda la entidad era a partir
de gadafi entonces esa lectura de
occidente no la hizo y pensaron que
sacando al gobernante a gadafi era
suficiente Y hoy en día nos vemos donde
el tema del control del tema de los
recursos miro energéticos del problema
de los bancos centrales que funcionan
distintos y como un país poco a poco
doce años se ha habituado a vivir con
dos tipos de gobiernos excluyentes entre
el este el oeste y con relaciones
internacionales y juegos geoestratégicos
importantes que no parecería que no
molestar a ninguno de la población como
tal que decir que Libia es un país
compuesto por diferentes tribus con
diferentes aspectos culturales y se
logró hacer una unificación bajo este
gobierno de gadafi Pero culturalmente
son muy diversas estas diferentes tribus
Y eso también dificulta esa cohesión
para formar esa identidad o ese
sentimiento de nación en en algunos
casos dagó su opinión que le falló hasta
a esta Primavera árabe en Libia Donde
había
muchísima expectativa a nivel
internacional y también la comunidad
internacional yo me atrevo a decir se
olvidó un poco de ese proceso de esa
crisis interna de esa guerra civil que
estaba viviendo
Libia y se alejó de de esta transición
política
bueno en primer lugar es importante
Resaltar el hecho de que Libia como la
mayoría de los países que salieron no de
del colonialismo en un país donde el
estado precede la nación al contrario de
lo que ocurrió en La mayoría de los
países occidentales y este hecho pienso
que a nivel occidente no ha tomado en
cuenta Esta variable a la hora de
empujar o de apoyar a los grupos en su
gente durante la Revolución de 2011
en segundo lugar Quiero quiero creer que
al principio Pues los libios tenían
expectativas muy altas en sentido de que
pensaban que al tumbar al régimen de
cadafi hubieran podido conseguir un
estado más estable que garantice sus
sus libertades y su bienestar y a cambio
pues
se encontraron envueltos en un en un
juego internacional que le superaban
primero entre las potencias árabes mismo
porque a veces se menciona mucho A cómo
se llama a
occidente pero se olvida también que en
Libia se jugó un cierto un cierto una
cierta competición de un una lucha no de
influencia entre Qatar y Arabia saudí el
bando de Qatar por un lado y el bando
saudí por otro Así que creo que al
principio pues pensaban llevar a cabo
una serie de
de reformas que permitían una mejora de
su vida pero se han visto superados por
por
juego internacionales quienes superan en
ese orden de ideas Dago para analizar
este conflicto que es una guerra civil
porque es una lucha interna Pero hay
muchos actores comprometidos quiero que
hagamos un análisis de algunos actores
importantes quiero comenzar por Turquía
que es un país que pues tiene un pasado
relacionado con Libia Libia fue parte
del imperio otomano en algún momento y
hay cierta conexión histórica con
Turquía en este momento Incluso el
gobierno de ankara ha desplegado allí un
gran número de tropas militares Para
apoyar diferentes bandos allí en en
Libia qué más está jugando Turquía allí
Dago Porque es importante para ankara
estar presente en este país de el norte
de África y hay que decir también le fue
suspendido ese acuerdo ya firmado con
uno de los gobiernos paralelos de Libia
para la extracción de petróleo en aguas
vividas en el Mediterráneo
exactamente y uno de los puntos muy
importantes en el conflicto de Libia es
que si si es una guerra civil Sí pero es
un tipo de guerra civil que se suelen
Llamar la guerra civil
internacionalizada porque los actores
internacionales involucrados en ese
conflicto hace que en más va más allá de
una mera guerra civil y en este marco
pues Turquía juega un papel de apoyo a
unos de los bandos de hecho Turquía
apoya al gobierno de trípoli reconocido
por la ONU y Turquía basa su apoyo a una
cierta
legalidad que con que da el
reconocimiento de la ONU a este gobierno
y de interés tú de Turco es de controlar
esta parte este del Mediterráneo Porque
todos sabemos no que con el problema con
Grecia pues Turquía Busca expandir Su
zona de explotación
económica en el mar Mediterráneo para
disfrutar de los recursos que hay debajo
de de de de este mar Así que
eso es el principal objetivo pensando
que es la que apoyar esta facción en
lucha en en Libia Pues si gana el el
Durán o Turquía garantiza una cierta un
cierto acceso a estos mares libio que le
puede permitir
ampliar Su zona de exclusión económica
claro Sí justamente uno de los países
que se ha quejado por este acuerdo de
explotación es Grecia y también chipre
que tienen pues obviamente intereses en
el Mediterráneo Alfonso sus opinión el
papel de Turquía en este conflicto hay
que ver quién es erdogan Yo pienso que
es importante ver la el protagonismo que
lleva erdogan Y si pensamos en la en la
Turquía de hoy del 2023 no es la misma
relación que tenía en 2019 por ejemplo
había un interés con el tema de la de la
de la guerra en Siria y con el
protagonismo y con todas las relaciones
un poco tensas con Israel y Turquía
después de todos los incidentes
diplomáticos
herptogamplió una posibilidad de tener
un protagonismo y sacarlos Totalmente de
acuerdo con el profesor ahora de ver
todos los temas de recursos miro
energéticos viendo siendo también
testigos que Egipto Israel con chipre
estaban también explotando el gas del
mar Mediterráneo entonces para él era
una oportunidad y a pesar de de todas
esas tensiones quien se hace en
contraposición
a la intersección del conflicto Turco es
son los rusos a través de la llegada de
los dagner y todos los los grupos de los
grupos de mercenarios financiados por
Rusia y esto cuando yo digo 2019-2020 es
importante
después erdogan necesita dentro del
conflicto del nagordo carabach
de Putin y los rusos y podría pensarse
que en un momento determinado y una
distensión de la presencia turca en el
territorio libio llegaron a un acuerdo
en un momento determinado Pero esto no
significa que erdogan haya dejado todo
es esa esa posición de volver a dar a
dar el volver a pensar en un imperio
otomano y una gran influencia dentro de
la región y creo que es una estrategia
que a pesar de de los temas de
regionales en la en todo podemos
nosotros ver cómo va a ir poco a poco eh
erdogan a posicionarse en el conflicto
de Libia y mantenerse vigente hoy en día
Alfonso usted Menciona un punto
importante habiendo ya dejado Clara esa
posición de Turquía en Libia Los
mercenarios de Wagner que están ligados
al gobierno ruso Estados Unidos ya ha
comenzado prácticamente se puede decir
una campaña a nivel internacional para
poderlos sacar de Libia ha habido
reuniones entre Egipto y Estados Unidos
de Cara a ver la posibilidad de cómo
retirarlos la presencia de Wagner en
África le preocupa la comunidad
internacional por el avance que están
teniendo Allí más allá del interés de el
petróleo a nivel político que tanto peso
pueden tener los Wagner allí no todo
porque va a generar una inestabilidad el
hecho de traer otro actor dentro de una
región muy de estable donde tenemos el
problema del tráfico armas el tema de la
migración clandestina el tema de los de
todos los los el drogas hace que sea
inestable y se mezcle con los temas de
la migración del grupo packer ojo el
grupo pactar también está presente hoy
de todo tipo de conflictos como el tema
en Ucrania y eso generaría una
inestabilidad y se convierte y se está
convirtiendo en un actor difícil para la
comunidad internacional Especialmente
los Estados Unidos
el acercamiento que ha tenido el señor
Porsche de la Cia en la región es
siempre buscando Cuáles son la las
posiciones y cómo la posición de los
gobiernos como el gobierno egipcio
el Sisi puede en cierta manera controlar
esto y no y pensemos también en Las
Guerras que vienen también en la África
subsana el tema del chat todo esto donde
ellos van a tener influencia en el acné
el daesh todo esto hace que sean que se
junten intereses por fuera de la ley y
que generen mucho más conflicto en la
región tiene una presencia muy fuerte
estos grupos Wagner sobre todo en la
República centroafricana tienen
muchísima presencia allí y están
desplegados prácticamente en todo el
territorio Dago su opinión sobre esta
presencia de estos mercenarios rusos y
la conexión que tienen con Libia con
este militar que controla o tiene mayor
posicionamiento en el este del país
jalifa haftar que prácticamente quien
los ha respaldado y le y los ha ayudado
a instalarse allí en el territorio libio
bueno en primer lugar hay que entender
que cada uno de los sponsor del sponsor
de los patrocinadores de los actores
libio manda tropas ahí el lugar también
ha mandado desplegado tropas desde Siria
hasta el territorio de Libia para ayudar
al gobierno que apoya Entonces yo creo
que desde mi punto de vista la solución
sería
seguir El ejemplo de Angola a finales de
la década de 80 del siglo XX en este que
Sudáfrica y
Cuba se retiraron ambos del territorio
angular
anguleño permitiendo una Los acuerdos de
visés por ejemplo Así que yo creo que
el gobierno de bruck no tiene interés en
ver a los debagner
y hay que darle una serie de garantías
de seguridad de que
pues ellos no van a sufrir unos ataques
porque porque Turquía apoya de forma
masiva a a su al gobierno que está en
contra sí que yo creo que mejor que todo
buscar una solución pacífica retirando
las los actores tanto Wagner como los
asirios que están luchando en el Libia
para que se pueda implementar un una
solución pacífica que sería beneficiosa
para cada uno de los actores pero encima
de todo del pueblo
pero pero Eso suena bastante prometedor
pero qué tan factible se puede hacer
porque finalmente estos actores están
allí por intereses Ya sabemos el interés
que hay a nivel petrolero energético
sobre todo ahora que por ejemplo Europa
la está pasando tan mal por el tema
energético por la guerra en Ucrania pero
siendo realistas qué tan factibles estos
las partes a negociar por sí mismas a
las partes libias sin estos actores
internacionales Eso sí es factible
la verdad que ese sería el mundo ideal y
hasta yo no me lo creo porque cuando se
ve la situación en Siria que es un poco
el espejo no de lo que está pasando en
en Libia se ve que los actores
internacionales siguen teniendo un peso
importante y
en en Libia pienso que no hay una una
salida de crisis a corto plazo no no lo
percibo salvo un cambio repentino en la
política interior del país No no veo
ninguna salida
una salida a corto plazo de esta
situación que parece como
como una trampa no que no que no tiene
salida y no tiene forma de ser de
resuelta de forma sencilla claro Alfonso
su opinión esta esta posible solución es
factible o cómo empezar a pacificar este
país por lo menos estabilidad política
hay que ver el trabajo que hace Naciones
Unidas en Libia y los altos
representantes Yo me acuerdo cuando
en el 2018 era el representante el
ministro de cultura libanés
estaba lo importante el enfoque de
Naciones Unidas el trabajo Fue el
fomento de las de la Democracia de los
valores democráticos en Libia a pesar de
no ser un país que tuviese
la tradición democrática era un un una
apuesta de Naciones Unidas en el cual se
podía establecer y generar en las
ciudades y las en los barrios y todo
elementos democráticos que permitieran a
ellos generar una madurez en el concepto
de la Democracia pienso que el trabajo
actualmente que hace la representante de
Naciones Naciones Unidas es volver a a
reiterar los temas democráticos y pienso
que un país con un alto un alta
identidad árabe su solución debería
estar en el para ahora mismo vemos hoy
las las movidas que hay entre doha y El
Cairo para generar por la preocupación
de ver al Wagner en los temas de
terrorismo entonces hay elementos que
son es un mínimo para los para los
países de la región los Países Árabes de
la región el cual no pueden no pueden
ser por ejemplo el tema del terrorismo y
el fomento al islamismo entonces un país
que ahora viene después de la Copa como
Qatar y que y que acá uno lo ve en el
trabajo
no la manifestación del giga del del
islamismo
un recurso mucho más políticamente
correcto al interior de los de los de
los del arabismo entonces creo que el
concepto democracia y la importancia de
contar más con los países de la región
Árabes y contarnos con el efecto
incisivo del sí sin el ejército que ha
apoyado a hascar sino el hecho de
generar diálogos que encuentren la
solución entre ellos y poder volver
darle al esplendor que da a la alivia
como en los años Alfonso eso me lleva a
preguntarle si tal vez ese modelo de
democracia que tenemos en occidente en
Europa que vemos donde hay una
institucionalidad fuerte en algunos
países que sirven para garantizar estos
procesos democráticos dentro de los
ciudadanos Ese sí es el modelo que tal
vez Libia quiera tener y le hago la
pregunta porque vemos usted ya
mencionaba el caso de túnez que es un
modelo democrático con muchos problemas
el Egipto pues tiene ahora prácticamente
Un gobierno dictatorial militar Y si uno
mira los países la región tiene muchos
problemas a nivel democrático porque
Libia va a ser la excepción y por qué va
a ser la apuesta Pero cuánto le digo la
manera como de como se mira la
democracia en línea debe haberse de una
manera sociológica y teniendo en cuenta
los clanes y los conceptos religiosos
cuando nosotros hablamos no queremos no
Naciones Unidas no quiere cambiar el a
los toec no quiere hacerlo solamente que
dentro de sus tradiciones dentro de su
de la sociología dentro de su territorio
generar espacios de diálogo que permita
que ellos entender que la mejor manera
de ejercer el poder no es como una
pistola ni es manejando esclavos sino es
una manera de construir una sociedad a
partir de la identidad por ejemplo dice
ejemplo y es yo no pensaría no estoy
pensando en la en las democracias que se
tiene que al frente en Europa ni todo
sino generar a partir de la identidad y
cultural árabe y de la y de cada uno de
los de las regiones hacerlo por ejemplo
Cómo cambiar esa filosofía que es
eduesora que es un puerto donde pasan
todos los los coyotes el que o sea es no
es cambiar la ciudad y cerrar la ciudad
a que no se den más migración
clandestina o decirle usted no puede
migrar es decir es manejar elementos que
le permitan a la gente de saber que lo
que está haciendo es un ilícito y está
exponiendo la vida humana frente a la
migración clandestina dagó su opinión es
la democracia el modelo para Libia es el
proceso para llegar a una pacificación y
una unidad política para ese país
Bueno ahí Estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con el señor Soria porque creo que
siendo un país árabe la solución viene
del panarabismo y como lo ha dicho Muy
bien pues no es todo cierto equilibrio
puede hacer la la excepción no Dentro de
este panorama del mundo árabe que no y
nos destaca por su grande democracia sin
embargo creo que
según la configuración que existe ahora
en el en el panorama político el único
camino viable para que se pueda elegir
un jefe de estado legítimo en Libia es
mediante elecciones y después el pueblo
libio puede de por sí decidir qué tipo
de gobierno puede poner en marcha en su
en su país de hecho
el término democracia no tiene la misma
definición que en Francia en Inglaterra
en Bélgica o en España Así que en la
propia Europa hay diferentes formas de
democracia Así que creo que eso también
puede ser aplicado a Libia pero en
primer lugar hay que poner una
instituciones reconocida por todo el
mundo y eso que es la parte más difícil
de conseguir Claro porque justamente
como lo decíamos el país está dividido
prácticamente en dos gobiernos Entonces
cuál va a ser la parte o el lado de este
gobierno Paralelo que haga una
convocatoria para unas elecciones y
lleve a cabo un proceso democrático
digámoslo así pero que sea reconocido
por el otro Ahí es donde toca entonces
entrar a negociar a las partes que es lo
que justamente no está sucediendo allí
dagó este escenario entonces puede ser
factible porque supuestamente dentro del
calendario electoral mundial Libia debe
ir a elecciones a final de este año para
para empezar a cerrar este capítulo pero
tan factible es que si se pueden
realizar esas elecciones cuando hay dos
gobiernos paralelos Quién las convoca
Exactamente eso es la incógnita porque
hemos visto en el año pasado pues hace
bueno el año pasado más o menos que se
intentó unas elecciones y no se pudo
llevar a cabo porque de un lado como
otro había ya problemas para reconocer
la legitimidad de este de estas
elecciones es lo que es por eso estoy
diciendo que la principal solución para
mí desde mi punto de vista sería empujar
no los los diferentes patrocinadores a
que actúen un poco Como hizo su como
hicieron Sudáfrica y Cuba en la crisis
anguleña porque sin eso el país va a
seguir en este en este círculo vicioso
de violencia mientras los civiles
mueren y tienen el país se convierte en
una una placa giratoria de la migración
irregular
Alfonso llevamos 12 años viendo este
proceso de transición de transformación
de cambio de revolución de guerra
interna allí en Libia y esto continúa
pasando una alta factura a la sociedad
civil que estaba acostumbrada a un
digamos a una forma de vida pacífica con
muchísima represión por parte de gadafi
pero con muchas garantías a nivel social
en términos de Educación y de salud por
ejemplo una línea inestable una Libia
partida en dos una Libia sin un proceso
democrático sin Un gobierno que tanto le
pesa a la región del norte de África y
al continente africano y al mundo árabe
no difícil pienso Por ejemplo en la en
la frontera porosa con Argelia y
pensemos que ya no está estamos en la
época postlica de la región y túnez
muchas de los de los de los problemas
que pasan por túneles Argelia todo
bienes de Libia y también viene del tema
pensemos que no solamente estos países
con el tema de Mali también es una este
es como un cultivo que está dispuesto a
explotar una olla de presión que estaría
dispuesta a explotar a mí me parece que
lo que tiene que hacer la la comunidad
internacional y creo que los países
vecinos que ese es el trabajo
desafortunadamente tú eres ha tenido
poder ejecutivo débiles últimamente pero
desde los esfuerzos en la después de la
Segunda Guerra del 2014
los países como túnez y Argelia
Estuvieron muy activos en buscar una
solución para Libia pienso que hay que
volver a la a la estrategia diplomáticas
regionales de los países del magreb y
donde se incluya a Egipto que puede que
tiene un gran una gran influencia sobre
el tema sobre el este y sobre el tema de
militar Y que siempre los ha apoyado mi
para que puedan lograr hacer una
solución pero mientras tanto estos seis
casi seis millones de habitantes están
condenados a vivir una economía y una
vida en guerra Claro que es lo que hoy
en día subsisten no tenemos los derechos
y es ver por ejemplo no sé hay que hacer
hay que recordar durante todos estos
doce años lo difícil que ha sido para
para Livia ver todo el tema la migración
clandestina en su territorio ver cómo se
generan centros de refugios que son de
personas que vienen del África
subsahariana y ver otro tipo ser ser
sensible a otro tipo de problemas ajenos
a ellos del de la gobernanza sino ver
otro tipo de conflictos que son los
regionales que vienen hacia ellos el
tema ciudadano mal y todo estos vienen a
la región como tal claro justamente no
tener una cohesión política una cohesión
lo mencionábamos en la agenda del
programa el tema de las fronteras es muy
complicado porque precisamente ha dado
paso a toda industria de migración
clandestina que es una industria
completamente macabra por el manejo que
le dan a el trato que reciben las
personas en estos centros clandestinos
que están tratando de llegar a Europa y
es una industria que mueve millones de
euros y de dólares simplemente jugando
con el sueño de unas personas que tratan
de buscar una mejor vida en el norte en
Europa me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa Dago quiero que
hagamos entonces la conclusión lo que
deja para usted estos 12 años que viene
para Libia Qué puede suceder en los
próximos meses en este país no tenemos
la bola de cristal pero pero podemos
hacer un análisis de lo que viene para
más adelante
bueno para hacer un recorrido muy muy
breve no sería como que los la
revolución tenía alta expectativa pero
fracasó no fracasó en cumplir los
objetivos que había prometido a la
población Libia ahora bien que hay que
hacer pues poner sobre la mesa que cada
uno de los actores del conflicto han
fracasado en lograr una victoria militar
que es lo lo más sencillo no porque
hasta fracasó en su intento de
conquistar al Al conjunto del territorio
libio y el gobierno de fujimori fracasó
en
en tomar el control sobre todo el
territorio Así que en lugar de mantener
esta situación peligrosa y
mala para sobre todo la población pues
mejor que los actores regionales como lo
decía el Señor pues empuje hacia la mesa
de de de de de de negociación con ayuda
de la comunidad internacional para que
se pueda alcanzar una una solución
pacífica para todos y Alfonso para el
cierre del programa su conclusión
pienso que
así parezca lejano creo que una vez se
solucione la crisis de Ucrania Vamos a
entrar a resolver los temas de Siria en
Libia pienso que ahí estará concentrado
la atención mundial porque los temas la
nueva el nuevo cambio de todas las
geoestratégico el tema de los recursos
minero energéticos va a estar ahí y es y
es necesario para la Unión Europea
volver a encontrar una paz en Libia
porque son los principales por ejemplo
para los italianos son los primeros que
suministran la energía como tal Entonces
pienso que
que es Los Socios los vecinos Árabes y
todos los actores árabes que van a estar
apoyados por Naciones Unidas y por los
países de la Unión Europea que van a
generar un cambio y el cambio tiene que
ser como lo hemos dicho de una manera la
democracia con la identidad cultural y
religiosa que necesita en este país pues
ya veremos cómo termina Cómo se
desarrolla esta situación allí en Libia
que más puede pasar para este país que
encara tal vez un proceso electoral a
final de este año que pueda llevarlo a
la pacificación y también a la
estabilidad política y social y
económica también Dago Alfonso
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia de France 24 es todo por
hoy En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera siga con France
[Música]